he actually once thought about becoming
a professional athlete
he says he's probably stole the fastest
runner of anyone at this conference
so i see that is a
open challenge to everyone that next
year he comes back and we have
running contests in central park please
welcome
rob thanks jared and uh
great to be here i'm really disappointed
i couldn't make it to new york in person
but uh this is sort of the next best
thing that i can get to go to the new
york
conference remotely so i've
given it's an our conference i've set up
all my merchandise appropriately i have
the
r hex cushion behind me i have my r
hex mug right here and if i step outside
being at covert 19 i have my r hex
face mask ready to go okay so
i'm going to talk about ensemble
forecasts with fable
fable is a package i've been working on
with mitsuhara wild for the last couple
of years
and uh forecasting is what i generally
do
um so let me first of all talk about uh
where i come from so i come from
melbourne not that one when i tell
people in the us i come from melbourne
they often say you mean melbourne
florida
no i come from this one the one in in
florida was named after the one in
australia we have about five million
people the one in florida has about 75
000 people
melbourne is famous for lots of things
but two of the things that it's famous
for is
uh as cafes and particularly coffee
in fact when i was in new york visiting
uh
visiting the meetup in new york a couple
years ago i found a coffee shop selling
what they branded as melbourne coffee
and so if you do visit us you can expect
to go to these iconic laneways with lots
of coffee shops and have our
amazing coffee okay
so that's sort of a segue to what i want
to talk about which is
i'm going to use this data set as a
example a vehicle illustration of a few
ideas so this is
monthly cafe turnover in australia uh
for the last
well since 2006 right up to the end of
2019.
i've left out uh i'm not going to talk
about 2020 because
code 19 means that the turnover is all
over the place
it's a little more difficult to forecast
and we have to use different techniques
but i'm going to talk about forecasting
um the la the year before 2019.
so you can see here's the here's the uh
the turnover in
millions of australian dollars um you
can see that it's
trended that there's some seasonality um
particularly it's spiking
up before the end of the year so that's
around christmas
there's lots of activity going on drops
down in january and then
i have this sort of pattern during the
year
so i just produced that having loaded
the fable package
with the data set which i've called
train because it's the training data
and i piped it into auto plot and the
name of the variable
in the in the data set is turnover
okay what i'm going to just uh before i
show you some any real coding i just
want to
introduce some ideas around how
forecasting works
and some of the concepts we use in
forecasting
so i've taken the data set and i've just
fitted a
model an ets model which stands for
expansion exponential smoothing
uh applied to turnover i'm see i'm
missing a pipe on my
second line there so i take the train
data i pipe it into
the model function i fit these models uh
this
this this model automatically it chooses
the trend and the seasonality and
whatever else it needs to select and
then i pass that
the missing part past that to generate
and i want five
new um series of
each one length so it generates these
five possible future series so it's
simulating the future
and it's simulating it five times and
for um
each each time it goes through it's uses
a different set of random
inputs into the model so you get a
different possible future
and one of the ways a useful way to
think about forecasting is it's
trying to look at the all the different
possible futures and think about
probability distributions
on those futures so that's
that's five possible futures and let's
just zoom in on the end part of that so
you can see it a little more clearly
and you can see each of the five sort of
captures the overall seasonality but
there's some fluctuations around because
of randomness
so i'm going to do that a lot more time
so there's about a thousand possible
futures
and uh we then look at those and and
look at the probability distribution at
each
of the um time periods over that
forecast horizon okay so let's
grade those out and think about what we
might do with those simulated futures
so the most obvious thing is you might
just take the mean of them so at each
time period you just take the average of
all of the
simulated future values for that time
and that gives you
a uh a grant that gives you the means
this blue line here
and there what when people talk about
forecasting that's what they often mean
they often mean that the
mean of those sample paths or sometimes
called the point four cuts because it's
one point for each
future time period but because we're
dealing with probabilities it's actually
much more interesting to look at some
other aspects of the distribution
for example prediction intervals there's
the middle eighty percent
of the sample paths as shown here
so for each time period we just grab the
middle 80 percent
and shade that and that gives us a range
within which
the future is likely to lie with about
probability 0.8
we could also do quantile forecasts and
in fact the edges of these prediction
intervals are quantile forecasts the
probability of it being above the upper
limit
is 10 the probability of it being below
the lower limit is 10 percent
so the bottom of this shaded region
is the 10th percentile or the 0.1
quantile
and the top of the upper region is the
90th percentile or the 0.9 quantile
okay so we can do different quantiles um
we could
compute all the deciles for example so
the deciles are
at the 10 20 30 and so on
um and they're shown as these blue lines
okay so when we think about
probabilistic forecasting this is what
we're doing we're looking at the
possible futures that might evolve and
what the probabilities
of those are what's the probability of
it being in different regions of this
space
and then we can look at what actually
happened because i've fitted this model
to the data up to the end of 2018
and then i've forecasted using these
futures
2019 and so you can see the blue lines
are the deciles of my forecast model
the black line is what actually happened
so that the next thing to think about is
just is to think well
how good was that forecast is is what we
predicted i'm close to what actually
happened
if we're just dealing with a point
forecast suppose we took the middle of
these lines which is the median the 50th
percentile
you can just look at the difference
between that and what actually happens
and you can take the absolute
differences
and average them and get some measure of
how good your forecast is
but because we're interested in the
whole probability space
we can't just take the difference
between each of these blue lines and the
black line
and get something that's particularly um
meaningful because you know there's only
a 10
chance is going to be above this top
blue line and 90
percent chance is going to be below so
you would expect the blue line to be
above the black line most of the time
so we need a way of measuring how good
that is
okay so let's this is the only maths i'm
going to show you for the whole
whole talk but i needed to introduce at
least one equation here to show how we
evaluate quantile forecasts
okay so if i let f be the
quantile forecast with a certain
probability at time t
so the probability might be 80 and it
might be at a particular time period
and then that's the value of that
predicted quantile and then the actual
observation
is y sub t so on that previous graph
that i had
the blue lines are the f
and the black line is the y and i've got
different f values for different values
of p
and this is the direction of t for time
okay and then what i'm going to do is
calculate the quantile
score which is this equation here so
it's the difference between what you see
and what you predicted so the y might
the black minus the blue
for all the different values of p that's
this guy here y minus
f and then but i weight it based on how
likely that probability is
and so that gives me a graph that looks
like this
so what i'm showing here is is this
equation in graphical form
on the horizontal axis we've got what's
in the
um in this bracket here yt minus
f sub pt so if it's zero that means
the black and the blue curves um are
exactly the same
uh if it's a positive value um then this
is positive if it's negative then the
absolute value makes this
a positive value as well the
weight determines the slope of these
lines
so you can see if i just stop it here
you can see that for when p is above 0.5
it's
weighted more strongly up here and less
strongly down there
but if i go to a smaller value of p
.05 then the probability of it being you
know below that number is pretty small
it's only five percent so you want to
weight the error
more strongly whereas if it's above that
value
that's pretty likely 95 year weight that
with not much weight there
so that's what's going on here with
these these
multipliers at the front
okay so what's good well a low value of
q is good that means you've
done well in predicting what's going to
happen in the future
those of you who've done looked at these
sort of things before you might wonder
what have i got a 2 out the front 4 you
haven't seen it with a 2 before
that's often omitted but actually i like
to put it in because it makes it useful
for interpretation
because if p is a half then 2 times a
half
is 1 and two times one minus a half is
one and so q
is actually exactly the same as the
absolute error
so it puts it on the same scale as the
absolute error but it's just weighting
it based on how likely it is that you're
going to exceed that number
the other reason for putting the two in
front is that when i average these q
guys
over all the possible values of p i get
what's called a continuous rank
probability score which is a measure
overall of the accuracy of the whole
distribution
so i average the qpts over
p and i'll get a measure of how good my
forecast was for that time period across
all the different quantiles as many as i
wish to compute
okay let's see how this works in
practice so i'm going to introduce a
couple of packages here
the sybil package which was largely
developed by eero wang and she's the
most distilled main developer she was a
phd student working with
me and die cook at monash up until
a year or two ago she's now a lecturer
at the university of auckland
which of course is famous in the art
world because i was born at the
university of auckland in the department
of statistics so ero
now works there in fact she inherited
ross ihaka's office
so she has some big shoes to film rasa
harker for those who don't know was one
of the two
people who started up the other package
i'm going to work with is fable
which the chief developer of that is
mitchell o'hara wilde who
works with me at monash so just a little
bit about the names
sybil is a time series tibble it's a ts
for time series
fable has two meanings one is it's a
forecasting table and secondly
it's conveys the idea that a fable tells
you
tells you something um important about
reality but it's not true itself
so a fable is a story that's not true
but it tells you something important
about reality well that's what a
forecast is
it tells you something about what's
going to happen
okay so let me just run through a quick
example
so i'm going to take the australian cafe
data
here it is here uh so this is a typical
it's monthly data i've got 168 rows and
two columns
the first column is a date index the
second column is turnover
in in
is that millions yeah millions of
dollars um so i'm going to filter it by
um take out the last year so that i can
fit my model to some training data
and there i'm going to fit a couple of
models an ets model and an arima model
i haven't got time to talk about what
these models are but they're two very
common models used in
time series forecasting and it
automatically chooses a couple of models
it automatically chooses an ets model
and it automatically chooses an arena
model for this data set
then i'm going to produce some forecasts
so i pipe that into the forecast
function and i say i want one year
it understands natural language i can
put that in as a string
and it knows okay one year means 12
months so it gives me 12 months for each
of the
for each of the models so it's given me
back a fable a forecasting table with 24
rows
12 months by two models so all of the
forecasts for each
each of these two models and it gives me
a distribution
so the thing about fable which is
different from my previous work on
forecasting is this
is built around forecasting
distributions not just point forecasts
it does give you the mean as well if you
need the point forecast
but we're going to be interested here in
the turnover which is the
distribution okay i'm going to pipe that
into accuracy
and say i want to use i want to
calculate the crps the continuous rank
probability score
and the root mean squared error so it
gives me back a little tibble
um with i'm just going to look at this
column
31.3 is the best okay so ets
is doing is giving me a value of 31.3
it's a little bit better than the arima
model it's also better on root mean
squared error which is a measure of
point forecast accuracy whereas crps is
a measure of distributional accuracy
okay so that's that's a quick intro to
quantile forecasting now let me show you
ensemble forecasting
so ensemble forecasting is where you
grab multiple models and you mix the
results together so instead of just
having one
model here we have multiple models and
the
future simulations are all mixed up
and we use the combination when we
produce our quantiles so the idea is
that not all the models are not
necessarily
correct of course they're just
approximations to reality so putting
them together
will give you better results i think i
said in the
blurb for this that i was going to talk
about covert 19 which
i'm not going to but i'm actually doing
forecasting for the australian
government
and this is exactly what we do we have
multiple models for covered 19
and we put them all together like this
and that's how we generate our
probability forecast which we
provide to the australian government
every week and they make policy
decisions
as a result and i know the same thing
happens in other countries there's a
very good team in the us
led by nicholas reich who does ensemble
forecasting for your governments
okay um so how do we how do we do
ensemble forecasting with fable
so here's here's what i had before
exactly the same filter the data fit two
models produce some forecasts
all we need to do for ensemble
forecasting is summarize it with a
mixture
so i'm going to take a district disc
mixture this is from the distributional
package
and i'm going to take the two
distributions
weight them equally and create a new
column which is a mixture distribution
and i'm going to
call this the ensemble that's it that's
all you have to do once you've got your
distributions you can create mixtures of
distributions as many as you want like
that
then i can pipe that into um accuracy
and say well how well did i do
um did putting these distributions
actually help
well i got a crps of 31.7 remember
previously my best was 31.3
so not quite as good as the ets model on
its own
often an ensemble does better in this
case it hasn't done quite
as well as one of the models another way
of
using multiple models is called
combination forecasting
and here instead of mixing them together
and in a mixture distribution
you take a weighted average of the
forecasts i'm not very often a simple
average
but the difference between this and
ensemble forecasting is you take account
of the relationship between the
distributions you need to account for
the correlations between the
errors of the distributions it's a
little more complicated to
to do the mathematics um you have to
sort of think about what are the
correlations between all the forecast
errors
the other hand the coding is really
really simple
just wanted to point out also that the
mean done this way is exactly the same
as the mean from the ensemble that's the
distribution is different but not the
mean
okay so here's my models and that's
all you need to do to compute computer
combination forecasts you just take the
models and you say i wanted to
add them together and divide by two or
you can do any linear combination here
create the forecast and now i've got 36
rows because it's going to give me one
for each of the two models
plus another set of 12 forecasts for the
combination
produce my accuracy and look what's
happened my combination forecast is
actually slightly better
in the distributional sense than either
of my models
the point forecasts are slightly worse
actually but the
point the distributional forecast is
slightly better
and i can create a tibble uh i can
compare my tibble with
the previous one and you can see where
the ensemble fits with the
three that i've just created okay so
there's
um let me just zoom in on the on the
on the on the graph here so there's my
plotting both my combination and my
ensemble at the same time
the combination is delayed down in the
first layer the ensemble is on top of it
and so you the ensemble is actually
hiding the combination there so let me
just flip the order
so you can see so flip the order now and
i've got the ensemble on the bottom and
the combination on the top
and if you look really really carefully
you can see that there's slightly
there's a little green bit
poking out here and up the top blue
green
so the ensemble width is slightly larger
than the combination width in this case
the point forecasts are the same so you
won't notice that
middle line changing at all it's only
the edges of the distribution that are
changing
so what's going on here is the
combination averages two distributions
so here i've got
one distribution here i've got another
distribution when you take the average
you get something in the middle
whereas the mixture distribution draws a
sample from
each of them so it's more spread out
like this
okay i see i'm running out of time so uh
let me just quickly point out that
combinations involve
i've said these combinations involve
averaging but you do have to take
account of the correlations you can't
just
average the densities or anything like
that you have to do it
correctly from a statistical perspective
ensembles just mix them and you can
ignore the correlations when you mix
them
the means are the same but other things
are different
okay the nice thing about fable is that
it
allows you to forecast many series
simultaneously
and in the rest of my slides which i
haven't got time to
to go through you can do all of the
forecasts for all of the australian
states so i've got in my
in my slides this set of code so that's
it
for doing all of the calculations for
all of the states
and i've got that on my github repo so
you can
you can have a play around with that let
me just switch to the end because my
time is up
the slides in my code are on my website
rob jayheinman.com slash nycr2020
the packages um also on my website is
lots of papers and packages and other
information a blog about forecasting and
so on
the particular packages i've talked
about today are in the tidy verts
collection of packages that stands for
tidy version of time series
and so tidyverts.org gives you links to
those packages
and we i have a textbook which uses the
fable package
com slash fpp3 it's written using book
down it's all free and online of course
and just a little bit of contact
information down the bottom there
okay thank you my time is up so i will
finish there
his tools fable we i've been using them
for a long time
it's a uh it's not a long time for as
long as they've been out i've been
testing them and they've only been out
for
a couple years and we've actually had a
number of members of rob's team come out
and speak at the meet up
so it's great to have you here thank you
for kicking off the virtual conference i
know it's very late
all the way over there in melbourne so
we appreciate you being our first
speaker
kicking us off uh we look forward to
greeting you in new york
again uh hopefully hopefully in the next
year